I want to welcome everybody back to
bright minded live with Miley today is
going to be one spectacular episode on
Wednesday Miley Cyrus celebrated women
on her bright minded Instagram live talk
show with some incredible guests I'm
talking Reese Witherspoon
Hilary Duff bebe Rexha and do a Lipa hi
hi I'm good how are you
the singer turn talk show host kick
things off with Reese who shared how
she's keeping bright in these dark times
well I definitely have like good days
and bad days I think just any kind of
adjustment to a new normal is it's
totally fine to feel however you want to
feel like at first I was trying to get
everything organized and go okay I do
all the shopping I gotta get recipes
like oh my god be tuning and then I was
like yeah just relax it's gonna be okay
the actress even gave some tips and
exercises for dealing with anxiety
during the quarantine everything you
have to see positivity you have to
create that in your life I'm reading
this really amazing book that talks
about everything you say out loud that
is negative has a 10times effect on your
body but everything you say positive
only has a four or five times effect so
think about that like how heavy negative
words or heavy expression or being
around people who have negative
self-talk for negative talk about other
people it just brings you down so I just
write like why is that Reese couldn't
leave without sharing her list of movies
to watch she recommends picking
something that brings you joy I have
like like a whole list of movies that
you have to see in your life like
they're really important like some of
them like Thelma Louise if you know
recent oh yeah it's amazing I'm raising
her sona it's an amazing movie we watch
mrs. Doubtfire the other night
remember I haven't heard that overboard
with Goldie Hawn is one of my bad bus
I can't it's so good um and defending
your life is a really great movie I
realize by these next guests with
someone she stands the apple of so much
that this person inspired her to be a
singer and an actress oh my god hold on
is this working it's working
perfect Hilary Duff opened up about how
this time has affected her family I love
your shows Club right-minded because
we're trying really hard to stay
positive over here and I guess our
bright side is that you know Matt and I
my husband we travel a lot and spend a
lot of time apart and right now we're
forced to be together and be really
present and be the only ones doing
anything for our kids and we're fully
capable of doing that you know and
unfortunately it's under really terrible
sad circumstances and but we're trying
to look at this time as a guest and be
positive and she also revealed that she
stands maile just as much as Miley
stands her I can't even believe what
you're saying to me it's so sweet and so
kind but really I think that you know
I'm I totally look to you for
inspiration on how to be cool and what
to wear and what you're doing and all of
this so and so for my fans to know you
can go from stalking someone behind
their tour bus to face on them live oh
wow talk about full circle up next bebe
Rexha hi bebe gave her take on how to
get out of the mental rut during these
times and to love on yourself
I have literally just been facetiming
everybody that I know and I've been
trying to actually call my therapist
yesterday and we did a we did a call and
um I asked her I said what can what can
we do in these times but I feel like I'm
being super hard on myself like I was
like I'm not doing anything with my life
yeah she's like we have to just be super
nice to ourselves the two also bonded
over which food
are currently obsessed over I've been
going bread I can't enough we need their
girl bebe who has been open about her
own struggles with body insecurities
shared her advice on how not to bully
yourself at a time when you're missing
out on the gym know that it's okay that
everybody's doing it this time cuz I
feel like we're all I mean it's okay
like we're going through such a hard
time right now it's okay to like have a
moment like a neat like as long as you
pick yourself back up life is about
balance
Miley wrapped up her show with you a
Lipa duo whose album future nostalgia
drops on Friday opened up how the
quarantine has impacted her press
schedule honestly back to back promo
trying to figure out how to do it like I
have like little things like this set up
in the house which I wouldn't normally
have like little mics with just all this
multitrack field recorder all that stuff
that was just like sent over that I have
to use to be able to make sure that I do
all the promo and everything that I need
to do with a bunch of you know radio
stations and journalists and stuff so I
can try and still promote my record
while being at home you know the pop
star even admitted to being confused
about whether or not she should postpone
her second album in May I was like I was
toying with the idea of whether I should
push it or release at a different time
it's also you know I made this record
because everyone was like oh second
record like there's so much pressure
behind it it's so um like I don't know I
I thought like a lot was riding on the
second record and I didn't want to like
let the pressure get to me so I just
wanted to make a record that just made
me want to dance and want to have fun
and took my mind away from it and
although it's scary to put a record out
right now I also feel like maybe music
is kind of what we need Miley ended
women Wednesday's episode with a little
duaa inspired dance lesson with her dog
Bo
[Music]